Have you ever needed to both start
and end a knitted piece with a hem?
Scarves and blankets are good
examples for using this technique.
Here is an overview of knitting
an item with a reverse hem.
You'll start with a normal hem
and knit the body of your item.
Towards the end of your knitting,
you're going to knit a marker row.
We'll talk about a couple
different methods of marker rows.
You'll knit the public side of the hem.
You'll knit a turning row,
knit the private side of the hem,
and then hang the hem
from that marked row and bind off.
One of the simplest marking rows is
to simply use a contrasting color sewing
thread and knit that in the row
that you want to mark.
You can use the contrasting color to pick
up the hem and remove
that sewing thread easily.
When you're done.
Try weaving ravel cord over
and under every other needle.
You can then remove the ravel cord.
Also, after you've picked up your hem.
Try slipping every other needle
for a marker row.
For this example,
we are adjusting our tension of our hem.
I'm assuming that you've already done
the first part of your hem,
so just repeat whatever tension changes
you did on the first part of your hem
on the reversed hem.
You'll knit the body of your piece,
knit the public side of your hem,
knit a turning row,
and the private side of your hem.
Now you put that marker row to work.
You can pick up every stitch
or every other stitch.
We just want to get
a nice join for the hem.
As always in knitting, you've got some
choices in binding off this reverse hem.
After you hang the marked row,
you could use a tapestry needle or
a double-eye needle and just run
a tail of yarn through the stitches.
This will secure this hem very well.
If you do this neatly,
the hem lays very, very flat.
One suggestion is to knit the last row
more tightly to reduce
the size of the loops.
Another idea is for a really fast finish,
is to just bind off those stitches using
whatever bindoff method you'd like.
Whatever method you choose, the hems will
be beautiful on both edges of your item.
Thank you for watching
Machine Knitting Now Learning Library has
hundreds of techniques on a variety
of subjects at all skill levels.
Please consider a subscription and let us
help you be a better machine knitter.